developing news this morning more
attacks on local teachers in this case
three in one day yesterday three
students now under arrest these
incidents happened at different campuses
across southern nevada foothill and palo
verde high and grant sawyer middle
school just last week you'll remember
the district announced a zero tolerance
policy for violence on campus we spoke
with a local psychiatrist who tells us
it is important for any teacher who's
experienced trauma like this to really
ask for help he also says it's important
to understand sometimes student violence
can be a cry for help
we do know that adolescents when they
are depressed they are less likely to be
sad they are more likely to be irritable
and angry and aggressive
and we have to consider this as the
impact of the pandemic
certainly a challenging situation right
now at ccsd if you or your child needs
help with mental illness mental health
in general ccsd has resources online
just head to eight newsnow dot com we've
got all the details there heather